it was a day football frozen fear 41
minutes into denmark's opening game at
the euros christian eriksen the team's
star player collapsed for 15 agonizing
minutes his teammates tried to shield
him as he fought for his life
now just eight months later football's
miracle man is back
a return he says he never doubted no one
is pushing me it's me pushing myself and
that was probably mentally the biggest
challenge um and ever since that would
overcome when i felt safe and i felt
like i was in control good hands
ericsson has been fitted with an icd
which is a type of pacemaker now a lot
of people in the world know that if you
do get something from a heart something
a heart problem and
and they give you an icd that doesn't
stop your world from from living you can
still do the things that
the doctors advise you to advise you to
do
christian erickson has gone from being
resuscitated on a pitch in copenhagen to
restarting his career here at
brentford's community stadium he enjoys
the game just as much while other things
matter to him even more it's been
just another
proof that
that the family is even more important
now than what it was before it was
important before but you do look at it
differently with your kids differently
um
so that has changed a bit but in the
football terms not that much
the enjoyment to play football was there
before and even now
after seven months of not really playing
football of course the enjoyment and the
excitement is slowly and
and quickly at the same time coming back
he's shown remarkable resilience so far
but erickson insists he's not just here
to make up the numbers i told him on the
first day there's no uh like there's no
reason to be uh
to be go easy on me otherwise i would uh
i wouldn't play football if that was the
case
shinki marike sky news